[Music]
well i guess it's time we start delving
into a new and brilliant story which so
far has really filled me with that joy
you get when you truly find a god-like
series that you know is literally going
to mind-melt people when the anime
finally does release and honestly after
starting this series the absolute
anticipation for what mapper and their
team is going to be bringing us later
this year has completely and utterly
multiplied an overall hype the mangaka
tatsuki fujimoto has honestly outdone
himself with this story even more than
his last one and i cannot wait to see
what other titles he may release in the
future so without holding back any more
it's time to grab those melons and get
into the one and only world of chainsaw
man in this first video we will cover
the first entire arc of the story that
being the introduction arc
so as the story starts off we find a
young dingy talking to his chainsaw-like
pet named pogita they continue talking
bringing up how tree cutting and selling
his body parts brings his debt down to
only 38 million and 40 000 yen
then she then turns to pachita saying
let's go and kill something
straight after this we see that he is
hunting a tomato devil using pachita
like a chainsaw dingy explains that
hunting a devil will make him three
hundred thousand dollars which will help
ease his debts for a birds after
destroying the devil then she talks to
an elderly man who tells him that the
devil's worth on the black market is
four hundred thousand yen however
denji's happiness is soon dashed when
the old man tells him that after
subtracting his debt and other expenses
from the total he only gets 70 000 yen
then she then takes his money from the
old man and thinks to himself that after
paying his water bill he's only left
with a measly 1800 and since denji and
pachita have got nothing to eat at home
too their meal for the day will be a
single slice of succulent bread as this
was happening the old man and his driver
were watching him from a car the driver
questions him asking why did he employ
brat as a devil hunter to which the old
man responds that he employed dingy
because his pops died before he paid
back his debt however the driver still
persists and the old man explains that a
real devil hunter wouldn't just let a
yakuza take the corpse afterwards he
then adds on that the good thing about
denji is that he always does what he is
told uncertain of this the driver yells
out and asks stingy to eat a cigarette
for a hundred yen which he accepts
because every penny matters to him as
denji eats a cigarette the driver speeds
away laughing and saying that they will
reach out to him if there's another
devil appearance and he better not run
away because if he does they will find
and kill him upon them leaving dingy
spits out his ziggy and tells pochita
that because of the hundred yen they
will be able to eat for another three
days
later at denji's shack we see the duo
eating a slice of bread and saying that
the normal things in life are just a
dream for him he can't ask a girl over
because of his run-down shack and he
heard that dating is quite expensive
anyway pogchita whines in response and
then she says that if dreams ever come
true then he wants to hug a girl before
he dies
as we flow back into a flashback we see
the kid denji standing in front of his
father's grave who had hung himself
before making his monthly payment to the
yakuza behind denji a younger but still
old man tells him to have the 700 000
yen ready by tomorrow or he will cut up
dingy and sell the pieces as the car
leaves we see pachita coming out from
behind a tree seemingly to attack dingy
the young boy though accepts his fate
and tells the chainsaw devil to kill him
because he's going to die either way but
bachita doesn't attack him instead
falling to the ground showing dingy his
wounds upon seeing him dying denji
remembers his late father and decides he
doesn't want anyone to die sitting up he
tells pachita to bite his arm because he
heard if a devil drinks blood its wounds
are healed and if bachita doesn't want
to die he has to do so vegeta bites his
arm while denji screams telling him that
their blood doesn't come for free and
that this is a contract so in return for
saving him pachuda must also help to
save denji as he doesn't want to die
either the next day the old man shows up
for the payment and as denji shows up
slaying a devil he asks the old man if
he would hire him as a devil hunter
after the flashback is over then she
lays on the ground saying he can't fall
asleep because he is too hungry and all
he can think about is his debt he tells
the little pochita that he knows what he
will dream of tonight saying that he
will flirt with a girl play video games
and fall asleep in her arms he tells
pegita that it's a pretty great dream to
which the pup yapped happily almost
instantly though denji spewed up blood
while at the same time the old man
randomly started banging at the door
saying that there was a devil
then she tells petita that his mother
died of a heart disease which made her
cough up blood as they leave dingy
thinks to himself wanting to just dream
even a little
soon they arrive at the abandoned
building with the devilers then she
questions the old man as he doesn't see
any kind of devil but the old man acts
like he didn't hear dingy and starts
thanking him for being loyal like a dog
hearing this then she starts feeling
awkward however the old man switches on
him telling dingy that he hates the
stench of dogs sadly as dinji was
looking forwards he feels something
pierced through his heart from behind as
he looks backwards he sees the yakuza
man with a short sword had stabbed him
and pochita through the heart the old
man tells dingy that they want power to
make money so they have made a contract
with a devil like he did revealing
himself the monstrous devil stands up
with a bunch of abnormal looking humans
around him while saying that it wants
the death of all devil hunters he goes
on to explain that he the zombie devil
has turned all of these stupid people
into his puppets by making them his
zombies it orders the zombies to kill
him and soon enough these zombies start
chasing the injured duo
as he runs dingy thinks that he just
wanted to live a normal life but no one
ever let him have even that sadly they
catch and kill him brutally slicing him
into multiple pieces and leaving his
remains in an alleyway dumpster as the
blood from dengi's nose reaches poaches
mouth the young devil thinks about how
they were cutting trees and how dingy
had told him that if he dies fighting
demons he would be worried about what
would happen to a cheetah wondering if
he would die of starvation or get killed
by another devil hunter though dingy had
said he had heard some devils can take
over dead humans bodies so if petita is
one of them he wants to give him his
body and run away from the town so that
the yakuza won't come after him
then she says it'd be nice if you can
have a normal life and die a normal
death while telling him to fulfill his
dreams for him
back in reality denji's body can torts
out of place as it slowly gets pulled
back together by bochita who is
connected to his chest seemingly fusing
with them inside of denji's head he has
a dream in which he is lying with
pachita on his chest denji calls
pachita's name to which pagida responds
with a cheerful wolf
then denji asks him if he has taken over
the control of his body like he had
asked him to to which pachita responds
by saying he has always liked to listen
to dingy's dreams then she is left
shocked but before he can say anything
pachita tells him that this is a
contract and that he will give denji his
heart but in exchange then she has to
show him more of his dreams he then
snaps awake calling for pachita but then
he looks down and is shocked seeing that
all of his wounds are gone he then looks
at his chest and finds a cord protruding
from his heart identical to pachita's
tail
screaming he yells out for his little
friend's name
in front of him though we see that all
of these zombies have returned again and
the zombie devil gets shocked seeing
dingy somehow had managed to survive
against the previous attack he instantly
orders these zombies to kill and devour
dingy though just blankly stares at the
mob thinking that all these guys already
had enough and why did they want a
better life but then he wonders if he is
similar and if he should have been happy
as long as he had pages here but he
still wanted a better life as well he
thinks to himself that dreaming is not a
bad thing everybody dreams and it's not
bad too but if they come in the way of
his dreams then they will have to die
dingy rips the kill switch on his chest
harder than a damn blade blade and a
horde of zombies rush at denji and begin
mauling him the zombie devil pipes up
saying to himself and the horde the
dingy has got to be dead after they ate
him but suddenly we see a zombie being
teared vertically apart by a chainsaw
dingy then reveals himself tearing
through the crowd of zombies fused with
pochita to become the one and only
chainsaw man the zombie devil tries to
say to dingy that they are the same but
gets completely ignored and then she
cuts through its eye then continues to
tear the devil apart easily with his
blades turning around he notices the
zombie horde have turned into devils and
since he is a devil hunter he's got to
destroy them all he literally starts
slicing his way through them one by one
then laughing like an actual madman as
he ruthlessly takes out the rest saying
that if he kills every single one of
them then he can say goodbye to his debt
a while later a car pulls up outside of
the abandoned building and three people
and suits come inside the girl notes
that it looks like someone has beaten us
to the punch as they realize that the
entire horde has been completely
obliterated as they look around and see
only one remaining devil standing there
one of these suits says that they have
got a living one however the mysterious
girl walks up to denji and says that he
has a peculiar smell
it isn't devil or human
she then asks him if he did all of this
but instead denji was too worn out and
he begins to throw up blood from his
mouth
while collapsing he asks the girl to
hold him but before he even realizes the
girl hugs stingy instead of holding him
and dingy's chainsaw form starts losing
its solidity
seeing him like this the girl says that
she knows he's a human one of the suits
ask the girl if he is possessed by a
devil to which she responds no because
you can see the possession on their
faces the girl then responds tell dingy
who was in her hands that she came here
to kill the zombie devil and as a public
safety devil hunter she offers dengy two
choices that he can either be killed by
her as a devil or be kept by her as a
pet human
she tells him as a pet he will get given
food in which then she asks her food and
a little surprised voice and what kind
of food would he get for breakfast
the girl answers while thinking that he
can have bread with jam salad coffee and
even more hearing he would be getting
bread with jam though and other things
for breakfast then she agrees saying
that it sounds like heaven before
collapsing
as time moves forward we see that denchi
has woken up and is heading somewhere
with the devil hunters his stomach
continues gurgling and he says that he
hasn't eaten to which the girl responds
that they haven't had breakfast either
so they might as well go and grab some
food upon hearing this denji awkwardly
says that he's broke and can't afford
the food to which the girl says that he
can pick whatever he wants and she will
pay for it then she is left shocked but
before talking the girl gives dingy her
code saying he will draw people's
attention walking around shirtless after
putting on the jacket then she peeks
over at the girl and thinks to himself
that people had always called him dirty
and smelly but with this girl it's the
first time he's ever been treated so
nicely and on top of that by a pretty
girl as well
with all this then she comes to a
realization that he truly is in love
with her
soon they arrive at a shop where they
order their food but suddenly a random
man runs in bleeding and yelling at the
cashier to help him the suit girl tells
him that she is a devil hunter and asks
him to explain what has happened the man
screams that a devil has kidnapped his
daughter and taken her into the woods at
the same time the chef comes up and then
tells them that their udon is ready to
watch the girl thinks for a while and
asks stingy what his name is obviously
denji tells her his name and she tells
him that she doesn't want her udon to
get soggy instead he will have to go and
kill the devil himself then she responds
that he's also having food though and
while quietly mumbling this he overhears
one of the devil hunters say that an
extremely experienced devil hunter is on
the job cutting him off she then asks
dingy if he forgot that he is her pet
and the only response that she wants is
a yes or a wolf as she doesn't need a
dog who says no
then she asks what she means in an
unsure voice to what she intensely says
that she has heard from a judge that in
the crime division they euthanize
useless dogs while he's terrified denji
stands there the girl tells him to get
to work fast before her noodles becomes
soggy and asks him what his answer was
to which he distraught dingy responds by
saying
yes as he runs off into the woods
thinking about how the girl was nice to
the point that he even liked her a
little however he now realizes that she
is just a damn psycho who is also
treating him just like a dog while
thinking he gets reminded of pogisa and
how he had died then he suddenly hears
the voice of a girl he heads over to
where the voice was coming from and
finds the girl he's after with a little
devil instantly after noticing him the
young girl confronts stingy asking him
to let the little devil go
she proceeds to tell dingy that her dad
had beaten her up but this nice devil
came and saved her she pleads for him
not to kill it
upon hearing this dingy starts thinking
what should he do and after a somewhat
difficult decision then she tells the
girl that they all three can run away if
they want and he also had a friendship
with a devil so he knows that not all
devils are evil the girl asks didn't she
if they can really run to what she says
that they totally can
however as the girl claps denshi's hand
and they all start laughing the girl's
face starts deforming slightly all of a
sudden dingy finds himself getting
lifted up and looks to find out that
it's the devil's actual form which are
transformed into a terrifying worm-like
devil shocked then she wonders what the
hell had just happened and the devil
tells him that he will show him
something cool before he dies and that
instead of a worm he's actually the
muscle demon he proceeds to manipulate
denji's arm he says that he can control
muscles and taunts him even more with
the girl's mouth saying how you'll mess
with the little girl he begins messing
with the girl's face or mahinu cackle
throughout his entire attack however
denji lets out a little giggle and then
rips his kill switch with his mouth
almost instantly decimating the muscle
demon with his chainsaws then she yells
at the devil then now he won't have a
problem killing a low life like him and
while the devil screams in agony denji
finishes him off once and for all by
casting the muscle devil into multiple
pieces from a distance we see the girl
eating her udon and saying out loud that
dingy sure is a useful dog coming out of
the woods tired while carrying the girl
on his back dingy responds with a wolf
before falling and collapsing the girl
catches him once again though and asks
him if he's okay
denji thinks to himself that she smells
good and apologizes to her for falling
as he accidentally ended up cutting
himself with a chainsaws and because of
that he continued to lose blood until he
fell
she asks did she how did his body even
end up like this to which he responds
that his pet devil pochita had become
his heart as he continues explaining his
disbelief and being alive the girl tells
him that historically speaking his
condition is extremely rare it's so rare
that it hasn't even been given a name
nor confirmed but she still says that
she believes him because she has an
especially good nose which is able to
tell that his best friend is still alive
inside of him and that his body also has
two sins one of a human and one of a
devil
as he hears this then she then blushes
and his stomach starts to gurgle again
reminding him that he wants to eat that
udon the girl then asks him if he can
feed himself to which dingy responds by
saying that he can however he stops
midway and realizes that he cannots
as the girl feeds and overjoyed dingy he
responds to her in ore by literally
barking like a puppy she then looks at
denji somewhat in disbelief that he can
actually enjoy a soggy udon as if he's
really like a dog then she blushes a
little and asks the girl what her name
is to which she responds that her name
is makima visibly taken back at the
beauty of your name denji asks what kind
of guy she's into makima thinks for a
moment and answers telling him that it's
people just like him then she thinks to
himself for a moment somewhat confused
and then says isn't that me
while danji thinks back on what makima
had just said he turns to her and goes
to say that he likes her as well but
then realizes she isn't there however
makima calls him over and it is shown to
him that she has taken him to the devil
hunters tokyo headquarters it has
explained through her that there are
over 1 000 devil hunters in tokyo alone
and that her bureau offers the best
staff but denji only thinks of what she
said earlier and starts imagining his
future with her makima gives denji a
uniform telling him that they normally
work in one and after he changes she
would introduce him to his colleague
after getting changed makima introduces
him to aki hayakawa saying that starting
today they are both partners then she
starts to complain hinting that he wants
to work with makima but before he can
say anymore aki drags him off while this
happens though makima walks up and tells
him that if he does well then they will
be able to work together while
patrolling the streets aki tells denji
to follow him for a moment once making
it to the end of an alleyway aki beats
him up punching him in the face and
kneeing him in the stomach afterwards
while lighting his smoke he tells him to
quit the devil hunter's bureau he
explains that people who became devil
hunters for weak reasons are the first
to die
saying that only the devil hunter is
still alive that he's worked with are
the ones with conviction he instantly
guesses correctly that denji only became
a devil hunter as he's interested in
makima as he finishes his smoke aki
throws it onto genji's chest and then
proceeds to spit on it to put it out
he then turns and says that he will tell
makima that denji got scared and
fearfully run away however dinji instead
hits him between their legs taking him
by surprise as he hits aki he explains
that today was the first day he felt
like a human and it was the first time
someone had treated him to a meal in his
entire life he tells him that if being a
devil hunter for those reasons is
shallow then he'll die to keep things
the way they are right now
aki stands up and fights back tackling
denji and continuing to punch him but as
he threw another punch he was once again
hit between the legs enraged then she
screams at him asking if it's because he
also likes her though aki was unable to
reply and collapses onto the floor
stating that he really did only aim for
the balls
returning to the headquarters dingy says
that aki got attacked by a testicle
devil but argue reveals that that was a
lie makima asks them if they'll get
along with both of them giving differing
answers but makima decides to put them
in aki's experimental squad either way
aki tries to say that he doesn't need
another weirdo as his team has already
filled with them but makima tells him
that his squad was meant to be
experimental which leaves aki confused
wondering what dingy is maki then
explains that denji can turn into a
devil and stunned aki says that cases
like them are just myths but she says
that he is a special type and if he
should ever run or quit then he will be
put down as a devil not understanding
the situation completely still then she
asks what she means and makima tells him
that it means that they will all be
working together until death do them
part
after leaving with aki denji asks if
makima is a good or a bad person in
hearing this aki tells him to be
grateful that at least he is still alive
but as he still insists on this question
aki tells him that she definitely is a
good person as he owes her his life
as he says this then she remembers how
she hugged him then cheekily remarks on
the melons that she carries around with
her which aki instantly perks up at
later on denji and aki start to live
together and the dream of the legendary
bread slice was completed but aki gets
annoyed after seeing the mess that dingy
leaves around the house and the amount
of times that he had to use the bathroom
pushing him almost to the breaking point
before erupting though aki receives a
call as there is an appearance of a
fiend in the eastner meda residence
after arriving at the location they head
towards the room to where they fiend
while heading there denji asks what a
fein is and aki explains that a fein is
a devil that has taken over a deceased
body of a person and are easily
identified by their heads as they see it
he explains more that fiends take on the
hosting devil's personality aki commands
denji to kill the fein and show his
devil power to prove himself however
then she decapitates and kills the devil
with a simple garden axe before aki
finished his sentence he goes on to say
to a confused aki that if he used his
power it would be a little overboard and
he wanted to give a painless death to
the faint archi gets angry and explains
that things may be half devils but they
are still devils and he shouldn't
sympathise with them as they don't have
feelings like humans
intensely aki tells him that a devil
killed his entire family right before
his eyes and those cops downstairs are
his amaze and they risk their lives
every single day for their wives and
children
everyone around them is serious but
dingy is not aki says that he wants to
kill devils in the most suffering way
possible and questions then she's morals
when it comes to befriending devils to
which then she says that if there are
any devils that could be his friends
then he'll take them as he never had any
before
however not impressed at his answer aki
tells him that he will remember that
before leaving the room
as denji looked down he saw some of
those melon magazines and he then
reveals that in reality he didn't want
to use his chainsaws as they will spray
blood all over his collectible manga
he then thinks to himself that he can
now shower eat tasty food and see a
lovely lady almost every day as well
here's everything he ever wanted already
but feels like something is missing he
notes that aki's goal is revenge or
something then curiously wonders if
makima has a dream of hers as well and
while thinking of her he comments that
he wants to touch some of her melons
dingy then realizes what he thought to
be impossible is now possible with his
current life
while he thinks back on what aki said
then she believes that now he has found
a serious dream and that is to touch
some of those beautiful melons
now over at the headquarters aki tells
the delirious denji to watch his mouth
before mahima informs him that she is
pairing him up with a new partner while
dwelling over this thought makima
explains to him that they pair their
agents up with new partners for
small-scale missions and patrols once
your friend does arrive though makima
goes to leave and warns him that she is
a fame
power then makes her entrance telling
all of the humans to cower before her as
she is called power
then she starts to wonder athens can be
devil hunters but as he sees her chest
he quickly accepts it and greets her as
he gets excited to work with her
well that officially brings us to the
very end of my first video into chainsaw
man and the introduction arc of i guess
you know obviously chainsaw man in
general this series is super super dope
and i'm super happy that i picked it up
before the anime did start releasing and
i honestly recommend that you guys do go
ahead and just start reading the series
for yourself because the mangaka foreign
deserves so much praise as well as in
two of his series fire punch and then
this as well have both been absolute
stunners so i i can't wait as i said at
the start of the video to see what this
guy puts out in the future and i
recommend that anyone go out there and
pick up his stuff honestly if you guys
have been wondering i've seen a lot of
comments asking where like kind of my
tokyo revenge's uh videos like this have
been over the last month or two on my
channel and the next video that i am
going to be putting out is going to be
my entire tokyo avengers explained video
for
the uh latest three deities arc of tokyo
avengers obviously main reason i haven't
been making like reviews uh in as much
like a tokyo avengers stuff in general
anymore it's just for the fact that i've
kind of like been busy with making these
videos they take about two weeks
sometimes to do one video alone because
they're an hour or two hours at a time
and reviewing things week by week can
become you know like quite repetitive at
some points i know it sounds as i said a
little bit silly but that's like one of
the main reasons why and i like to you
know enjoy the series for the main
reasons that i got into it in the first
place but anyway i'm still enjoying it
at how it is now and uh i can't wait to
you know kind of like talk about it in
my next video which i'm going to put out
one after that is going to be the jiu
jitsu kaizen uh hidden inventory arc
explained and then i'll probably do part
two for this depending on how you know
well this video does so if you guys have
enjoyed this video and want to see you
know obviously part two for this or the
bat devil art i think it's the next dog
i'm pretty sure it is then make sure you
leave a like and obviously subscribe and
leave a comment down below and all that
kind of jargon that i've mentioned like
four or five times already but anyway
for now it's been your professional
degenerate and i'll see you all
but anyway for now it's been your
professional generic diavolo and i will
see you all in a birth bye
[Music]
you